est-ce que la vie du passage a beaucoup
changé oui en quoi en moins bien
pourquoi parce qu'il y a beaucoup moins
de
[Musique]
monde les mésaventures du piéton
remontent aussi loin que l'existence des
ville pour chasser par les chars romains
coincé par les carrosses qui
onembouteillé les allées royales du
grand siècle il suffit pour s'en
convaincre de relire les chroniqueurs
c'est sans doute l'une des raisons de
notre émission essayer de savoir quelle
relation le piéton entretient avec la
ville aujourd'hui peut-elle enfin nouer
avec lui des liens d'amitié et de
sourire à première vue c'est douteux
mais c'est à voir avec l'apparition de
la voiture l'agression contre le
malheureux qui va à pied s'amplifie il
est chassé de la chaussée et l'énorme
vague de bruit l'assourdissant et
polluant vacar mécanique le transforme
en pentin
silencieux
[Applaudissements]
garde-toi à droite mon frère piéton
garde-toi à gauche sinon
[Applaudissements]
gard-toi tout a été dit et écrit sur les
rapports étroits qui unissent l'homme à
la machine automobile dans les années 20
monsieur Paul Morant peignait avec
enthousiasme l'homme nouveau dans un
beau roman l'homme pressé depuis il est
devenu agité l'homme frénétique même la
belle auto bien astiquée le soir pour
sortir en weekend est devenu le symbole
de l'aisance mais aussi de la puissance
et l'homme est devenu l'esclave du
symbole objet de consommation dans
l'esprit des constructeurs l'OTO devient
objet d'adoration dans celle des
consommateurs alors la ville étouffe le
piéton est traqué partout on ne se parle
plus on
[Musique]
roule
[Applaudissements]
pourtant au cœur des villes des espaces
existent secrets et délaissés révolté
harrassé par le bruit de nouveaux hommes
parlent il faut disent-il sauver ces
espaces lieu de paix et de silence où la
beauté de la lumière vous emporte
jusqu'au rive du
[Musique]
rêve
ces lieux depuis des siècles chaque
ville les a inventés patinés avant la
naissance du fonctionnalisme et de la
religion de l'angle droit les cours se
succèdent s'entremèlent s'entrecroisent
et s'adjoignent des passages et des
chemins de
[Musique]
mystère
le 19e siècle pour des besoins mercantil
organise invente c le mot ces endroits
que l'on appelle des passages ou
galeries qui font floressent sous le
Second Empire surtout à Paris mais aussi
à Marseille Lyon ou
Milan travaillez ici depuis combien de
temps Madame temp 30
[Musique]
ans est-ce que la vie du passage a
beaucoup changé oui en quoi en moins
bien pourquoi parce qu'il y a beaucoup
moins de
monde Louis c'est vrai beaucoup moins de
monde
qu'autrefis microcosme de ville le
passage des Panoramas est avec le
passage des Princes ce qui donne le
temps de l'époque le plus fréquenté le
plus réputé aussi le monde élégant s'y
retrouve chez les marchands à la
toilette ou dans les salons de
thé triomphe de l'chit tecture de fer la
galerie ou le passage tient à l'abri des
intempéries comme du trop brûlant soleil
les proveneurs qui vont deun passage à
l'autre qu'est-ce que ça représente pour
les gens du quartier le passage j froid
pas grand chose pour les gens du
quartier
et le fait de se promener à l'abri c'est
agréable moi je sais pas ça me détend
venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez ce passage depuis très
longtemps oui mon Dieu oui il est au
moins aussi vieux que moi oui ce n'est
pas le plus animé de tous ceux du car à
mon sens enfin qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous le
passage bien un peu de tranquillité il y
a pas de voiture et puis
c'est CIT l'abri de la
pluie et
puis une ambiance assez silencieuse je
crois qui qui change un peu de
l'animation des boulevard un peu feutré
un peu feutré voilà le mot est plus
[Musique]
élégant
autrefois savoir fler était une qualité
aussi prisée que savoir faire des
affaires car si le piéton était roi dans
ses galeries élégante c'était aussi pour
que prospère l'industrie industrie de
luxe ou
[Musique]
d'illusion dans Chrin
ré comm
matin le palais royal créé au 17e siècle
est situé au cœur d'un réseau d'escalier
de voûtes et de galeries qui raisonne
des échos de ce fantastique lieu de
plaisir et de fête le régent puis
Philippe d'Orléan en furent les maîtres
absolus puisque même la police n'y avait
pas accès il n'y avait là écrire à
balzag dans les illusions perdues que
des librairies de la poésie de la
politique des marchands de mode enfin
des filles de joie qui venaient
seulement le soir nous y avons
rencontrer le célèbre Raymon Oliver rmon
Oliver vous êtes installé au palais
royal depuis combien d'années bien ça va
faire 28 ans révolu et rentrer dans la
29e année s
rire le val royal est un riche quartier
toutes les jeunes filles sont am vous
ave bien connu le Palais Royal et vous
avez bien connu tous ces fantômes oui
j'ai vécu parmi les fantômes c'est cocto
qui disait vous y dînerit parmi les
ombres et c'est Collette qui disaent le
moineau se pi dans le pal Royal c'était
des boutiques qui servaient à boire et à
manger ainsi que d'ailleurs des
marchandes de livres et beaucoup de
maisons de jeux et aussi un petit peu de
prostitution enfin ça sur le bout des
lèvres c'est fenêtres en demi-cercle
qu'on appelle des castors lorsque les
filles n'étaient pas assez riches pour
s'offrir un castor à à elle toute seule
elle se mettaient à deux d'où le nom de
demiastor qui est le le synonyme de
péripathéticienne n'est-ce
pas les galeries aujourd'hui sont à peu
près vides en tout cas on ne trouve
pratiquement plus de commerce de boisson
non les commerces de boissons presque
disparu aujourd'hui l'on redécouvre ce
cheminement possible pour les piétons
depuis la rive gauche jusqu'à l'opéra
par le célèbre jardin monsieur lè nous
explique le projet sous ces voûtes là
vous apercevez la cour du Conseil d'État
la place du Palais Royal et derrière le
musée du Louvre
naturellement il s'agit pas de
réserver la totalité de quartiers qui
sont très actifs au piéton naturellement
mais d'instituer entre les différentes
galeries et puis certains espaces
publics très intéressants de ce quartier
des liaisons faciles des liaisons
agréables des liaisons à l'échelle
humaine à l'échelle du cheminement d'un
piéton alors ici nous voyons bien par
exemple la galerie Vivienne avec cette
entrée qui est mal signalée et qui est
très désagréable d'abord nous voyons
aussi enfin nous essayons de deviner là
ce qui était la sortie également de la
galerie Colbert qui est actuellement
masquée par les établissements qui s'y
trouvent
[Musique]
installés et par conséquent nous avons
la nous voyons nous avons l'issue de
deux galeries extrêmement intéressantes
et parmi les plus remarquables de le
architecture et de leurs espaces
intérieurs vers la Bibliothèque
nationale avec son jardin donc l'idée
toute simple c'est d'abord de relier les
deux galeries il suffit de très simple
percement pour que la galerie Colbert
soit rejoint jointe à la galerie
Vivienne et que la galerie Colbert
naturellement soit rouverte aussi à la
fréquentation du
[Musique]
public ceci d'autant plus qu'il faut
souvenir qu'il y a 6 ou 7 ans il était
tout simplement question de détruire la
galerie Colbert et d'y édifier à la
place un ensemble tout à fait ordinaire
de bureau n'est-ce pas qui aurait
absolument perdu tout le charme de cet
espace de la galerie alors ça montre
bien les trois niveaux d'intervention de
la puissance publique d'abord empêcher
qu'on détruise les passages de les
protéger à chaque fois qu'elle en a
l'occasion deuxièmement leur créer
l'environnement le plus favorable
notamment par des mesures de
réorganisation de la circulation
automobile troisièmement prendre des
mesures un peu incitatrices aux
interventions privées par toute une
gamme de moyens qui serait trop long de
détailler de manière que cette
opportunité soit exploitée par les
commerçants les propriét
DEES
la plupart du temps les passages qui
étaient raccourcis par rapport à
d'autres voies de la ville étai des
passages un peu corridor tandis que le
parti qui a été pris pour le passage
Vivienne est assez différent c'est au
contraire un passage qui s'est force de
souligner enfin d'élargir
l'allée
lui donné d'ailleurs une très belle
décoration à la fois au sol et le long
des
paroir de tasser de façon très
importante finalement et l'entresol et
l'étage généralement réservé à l'habitat
pour affirmer au contraire la largeur de
cette
circulation il y a un soin dans la
conception de ces espaces qui est tout
particulièrement remar
et qui je répète bien que les passages
de manière générale soi très bien
traités fait quand même de la galerie
Vivienne sans doute un des joyaux des
passages couverts de Paris par sa
disposition et le parti d'architecture
qu'elle
exprime les galeries avec leur
atmosphère sous-marine exercent sur les
poètes une attraction puissante and Br
glagon les enchanté le spingler elle a
choisi de vivre dans cet espace clos
propice à l'explosion
[Musique]
créatriceux deux vivant des yeux de
fl
[Musique]
cuxux une femme s est ou si ou bien pré
le voir le
voir est no ver tu
[Musique]
voud vous êtes un poète et un poète qui
a choisi de vivre dans une galerie
pourquoi qu'est-ce que cela évoque
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous et
bien pour moi les galeries sont des
lieux d'amour je pense que que ce sont
des ventres pour consoler les âmes
blessées alors je me sentais très cœur
blessé papillon qui ne savais plus où me
poser dans ce monde que je ne comprends
pas et un jour j'ai eu ce choc qui est
une épousaille en découvrant que Paris
avait des galeries des galeries
absolument délicieuses de rêve et qui
sont aussi très mal comprises abandonné
euh perdu insolemment abandonné et je
trouve que c'est pas très digne d'une
France qui se dit au plus haut Nive
niveau de la culture alors moi je me
sens une espèce d'âme de surréaliste et
ce monde de rêve C espèce de de de
temple des
rues espèce de fleurs à
mystère dans ce silence incertain et
complètement introuvable c'est chapelle
ce côté orthodoxe enfin ce côté fabuleux
qu' ces lieux évidemment a enchanté mon
âme
[Musique]
gingler vous me disiez tout à l'heure je
suis une femme orientale vous avez vécu
je crois en Algérie j'ai vécu en Algérie
pendant la guerre alors j'ai découvert
qu'en effet j'étais très orientale
est-ce qu'on peut dire que peut-être
vous essayez de retrouver ici cette
atmosphère bien j'ai pensé que ce serait
possible et je suis étrangement déçu
parce que ici je ne l'ai pas trouvé
c'est un véritable crime de laisser ses
galeries mortes coulant de poussière je
crois qu'il faut avoir un amour fou pour
les galeries pour les sauver n'est-ce
pas et il faut les sauver des grossistes
des entrepôts des des boutiques
vulgaires ça devrait être des espèces de
casebas avec des métiers rares et il y
en a plein il y a plein de métiers
excentriques qui adorent être là des des
des chocolateries viennoises des des
marchands d'herbes j'ai connu un un
coiffeur des Indes qui aurait voulu
coiffer ici il y a toutes sortes de
possibilités superbes mais qui sont
rejetées et ça c'est un véritable
scandale
g spingler vous avez créé en bas une
vitrine ça n'est pas un magasin en aucun
cas tout non je n'ai aucun régistre du
commerce je suis bien trop folle pour
avoir des des des pieds sur la terre et
être marchande j'ai horreur de ça mais
j'ai besoin de sortir tout ce qu'il y a
en moi et d'amener la beauté autant que
je le peux partout alors j'utilise tous
les coins il y a cette vitrine je veux
créer pour pour les autres pour les
enfants qui passent pour une joie
culturelle c'est un théâtre c'est un
théâtre avec mes états d'â les statues
sont en deil elles sont en fête j'écris
des phrases de Nietzsche de Breton les
miennes et je crois que c'est ça forme
un lieu de culture
[Musique]
vivant Robert Capia depuis combien de
temps êtes-vous installé dans cette
galerie
verododa depuis 15 ans je vis galerie
verododa je dis je vis parce que j'y
travaille et j'habite j'habite
l'entresol de ce passage et c'est une
c'est c'est vraiment je suis là par coup
de foudre enfin c'est j'ai découvert
tout à fait par hasard ce passage il
pleuvait on
m'avait indiqué un commerce pas très
loin d'ici je suis entré tout simplement
pour ma brité de la pluie et ça a été
une sorte de révélation vous savez la
galerie verododa est un lieu clos et
désert et Dieu sait si à Paris dans le
centre de Paris il est difficile de
trouver un lieu où l'on ne rencontre
personne et où il n'y a pas de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bruit c'est un lieu qui vit euh sous le
régime de Charles 10 c'est-à-dire que le
matin à 6h30 un gardien passe ouvre les
grilles le soir à 22h le gardien passe
et ferme les grilles et c'est un lieu
qui a le privilège pourrais-je dire de
ne pas avoir bougé c'est absolument le
temps arrêter la galerie verododa
car le le le commerce peut-être est
tombé en sommeil donc les les les
promoteurs n'ont pas envahi le lieu
et euh on lorsqu'on vit dans ce dans
dans cette galerie dans ce passage on
est hors du temps on je peux même dire
on perd la notion du temps car songez
que c'est un lieu où il ne passe pas de
voiture et où il y a de moins en moins
de gens de moins en moins de gens qui se
promènent je veux dire elle a été très
très fréquentée en 1830 c'était un lieu
parisien de haut luxe et au cours des
année le le commerce a disparu de ce
[Musique]
lieu vous n'avez jamais envie d'aller
habiter ailleurs avec du soleil avec des
arbres pas du tout pas du tout je
déteste le soleil je déteste la nature
et c'est une de choses je ne comprends
pas du tout si vous voulez l'engouement
qu'il y a actuellement à cette recherche
d'avoir la peau bronzée là je n'ai
nullement nullement nullement envie de
d'être au solil il d'être grand terre et
encore moins de voir de la végétation je
n'aime pas ça du tout est-ce que vous
aimeriez voir une animation plus grande
dans la galerie les boutiques ne sont
pas toutes occupées pas du tout vous
savez je crois que le charme de la
galerie verododa c'est que c'est un lieu
mourant mais qui n'est pas encore mort
et je crois que c'est là le charme qui
se dégage lorsqu'on pénètre dans ce
passage je crois que c'est ça c'est un
pe un petit peu si vous voulez comme la
ville de
Venise quel est le charme de Venise je
crois que c'est cette espèce de
d'atmosphère mourante mais qui ne meurt
jamais et ça je crois que ça dégage
énormément de
[Musique]
charme